Here's everything I make for breakfast on the farm
as a mom who eats an ancestral diet
and as someone who avoids seed oils,
artificial sugars, dyes and preservatives.
We start by walking over to the vegetable garden
and doing some harvesting,
focusing on the overgrown summer squash.
Squash can be so versatile
and my favorite thing to do right now
is shave them thin with a mandolin for a squash salad.
We collect the eggs from the chickens,
say hi to the cows who were just moved to a fresh salad bar,
and then put our ingredients together to get breakfast started.
On the menu our 100% grass fed buddivores,
a traditional South African sausage,
corn free soy free pasta, raised egg,
summer squash
and leftover oats that were soaked overnight before cooking.
I finished off the eggs by drizzling some schmaltz over the yolks,
creating a crispy white and perfectly sealed yolk with a soft center.
Breakfast was simple and delicious
and we all jumped in the pool afterwards to cool off.